Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I am going to
explain an episode called “The Rank” from the Thai
mystery thriller series called “Girl from Nowhere”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in an all-girls high school
in Thailand that is different from ordinary
schools because it values beauty more than
it values education. In the opening scene,
the director of the school announces that the
finals of the annual shining star competition
will be held soon. The top ten beautiful
girls of the school will be awarded,
among whom, one will be named the shining star of
the year. The only category the students need to
exceed in order to get the award is beauty. The
director claims that the winner will receive an
honorary trophy and as well as a special
prize along with several other privileges
throughout the rest of the year. The top ten
contestants will also receive extraordinary
privileges. She ends the announcement by saying
that there are no ugly people in the world, just
lazy ones. A new student Nanno is in front of the
school when a thin leaf falls on her and makes a
tiny cut on her cheek. She doesn’t flinch or look
surprised, almost as if she had been expecting it.
But with the scar on her face, she can hardly
be the winner of the beauty competition.
In the following scene, we are introduced to one
of the popular girls named Ying. She is currently
ranked in the tenth position in the beauty chart
and is famously known as princess ten. As she
walks through the hallways, her classmates try
to snap a picture of her to admire her beauty.
The new girl Nanno enters the classroom and is
made to sit beside Ying by the teacher. Ying is
also the class leader so the teacher wants
her to help Nanno catch up with the others.
Ying happily welcomes the new girl to the seat
beside her, but it isn’t clear if she genuinely
wants to be Nanno’s friend, or considers her
an enemy. Nanno is just as beautiful as Ying,
if not even prettier, which is clearly
making Ying uncomfortable. Her face glows
in happiness when she sees the scar
on Nanno’s face. To act sympathetic,
she asks her what happened. Nanno tries to dismiss
the matter but Ying claims that in their school,
they must take good care of themselves, and a scar
on the face is a huge problem. Their conversion
is interrupted when the teacher asks them to
keep quiet. After the class, Ying brings Nanno
to the top ten tower. It is a building exclusive
to the girls who are on the top ten beauty list.
The tower provides them with tasty food,
expensive makeup, and a luxurious lifestyle that
ordinary students are not privileged with.
Every student has a rank in the beauty list
that is updated in real-time. If anyone’s face
loses its beauty, their rank drops immediately.
They all have an application that shows the
ranks of all students. Since a top ten can
bring one friend inside the tower, Ying asks
Nanno to come with her. Nanno is fascinated
by the luxurious interior. They eat a wonderful
lunch while talking about several things. Nanno
thanks Ying for providing her with such a great
opportunity to be her friend. However, Ying’s
intention is not as good as she thinks it is. She
boasts about her lifestyle as a top ten and claims
that if Nanno wasn’t her friend, she would have to
eat with ordinary people in the school cafeteria.
Nanno compliments her, commenting that she is
very down to earth, which couldn’t be further
away from the truth. In reality, Ying can do
anything to stay in the top ten and can hardly
survive outside. After the meal, Nanno brings
out a bar of chocolate and starts to eat it.
Ying looks at the chocolate, wanting to try it
but scared of gaining weight. When Nanno insists,
she takes a small bite of it. Following
that, a girl named Chompoo approaches Ying,
calling her princess ten. She has been Ying’s
minion for the past few years. Before Nanno, Ying
used to bring her to the tower as her friend, so
Chompoo is hurt when she sees them together.
To make her feel better, Ying hands her a piece
of cake. The workers drag Chompoo out because she
isn’t allowed to step inside the tower without
a friend. After she is out, Ying says that she
feels bad for Chompoo because she has an ugly nose
and a big forehead. Nanno eyes Ying, knowing very
well that she deems other people inferior
to her because she is prettier. Just then,
the bell rings notifying them that the number one
on the beauty list and the queen of the school,
Gade has arrived. They welcome her like an
actual queen as she descends from the stairs.
Ying introduces the rest of the beautiful girls
to Nanno. To make Ying feel better about herself,
Nano comments that she is as beautiful as
Gade, so she deserves to be this year’s queen.
Ying then urges her to scan her face in the app
and see what rank she is in. But her face drops
when the app says Nanno is in eleventh place.
She is surprised to see her new friend is also
her biggest competition. Ying congratulates
Nanno but worry is evident on her face.
When she leaves, we see Nanno looking at her
smugly. She knows that Ying is pretending to be a
good person. She has only befriended her to teach
her a lesson. The following day is the worst one
for Ying because she wakes up with a large
pimple on her nose. She is then informed by the
app that she had dropped to the eleventh position
because of the pimple. Nanno has taken her place
in the top ten beauty list. She pops
the pimple which makes it even worse.
At school, the girls who once used to follow her
around for a picture, now start to make fun of
her red nose. Ying’s day only gets worse when
she sees that her minions have surrounded Nanno
and are praising her beauty. When she walks
in, everyone goes silent. To add to her misery,
Nanno calls her princess Ten. Ying laughs it off
trying to make it seem like she doesn’t care about
the ranking. But she is visibly jealous when she
sees Nanno wearing a bow that is exclusive to the
top ten girls. A girl asks her if she had eaten
sweet stuff for her to get the pimple. Just then,
Ying remembers the chocolate Nanno had given her.
She starts to suspect her for deliberately feeding
her sweet so she would get a pimple.
During the lunch break, Ying walks into the
top ten tower out of habit but the workers
ask her to get out. Nanno tries to help her
saying that she can be her plus one but the former
princess ten says she misses the cafeteria’s food
and leaves. However, after eating the first
bite of the food from there, she almost
chokes. The other students laugh at her reaction,
making her feel worse. She then goes to the public
washroom which is even worse. She places
toilet paper on the floor to step inside
but has to run out midway when a lizard falls
to the ground near her. Suffice to say that she
is miserable outside the luxury of the top ten
tower. She is looking for cosmetic procedures
in a magazine when one of her former minions
tells her that she is now in the sixth position
of the top ten list. Ying is left speechless,
everyone she thought was lesser than she
is now getting on the list. She runs away crying
at the thought of no longer being beautiful.
The following day, she dreams of winning the
shining star award. But the director screams
after looking at her acne-filled face. She wakes
up panting from the nightmare and notices that
her rank has dropped to number twenty-one. Her
face has two more pimples which means she won’t
be getting back on the list any time soon.
She goes to the school with a face mask on and
stares at the top ten tower. Later, we see
her at the pharmacy looking for a medicine
to treat her acne. She meets Nanno there and runs
away, embarrassed of her face. Outside the shop,
she bumps into Chompoo but doesn’t talk to her.
Nanno whispers something in Chompoo’s ear, panning
something else for Ying’s downfall. The following
morning, Ying wakes up to see her acne has cleared
up completely, thanks to the medication. She
squeals in happiness when she notices she is back
to being number ten on the list. She is overly
jolly at school, which even her friends think is
weird. She asks one of her minions to play swing
with her but she declines. Instead, the girl shows
her the new ranking which says she is still at
number eleven. Ying is once again devastated.
Nanno tries to make her feel better and asks
her to join her in the swing. However, Ying has
different plans. She has had enough of playing
it safe, hence, to get a position in the list,
she pushes Nanno off the swing. The poor
girl falls face first and bruises her eyes.
Because of this, she drops from the ranking
and Ying gets back to being princess ten.
She then snatches Nanno’s bowtie and walks inside
the tower, without even bothering to pick her
friend up. But as soon as she leaves, Nanno opens
her eyes, as if she had already planned this out.
Inside the tower, the top ten girls do not notice
Ying on the sofa and start to talk badly about
her. They make fun of her for being number ten
for her entire life. Queen Gade claims that Ying’s
mother’s genes are to blame for her failure in
life. The girls laugh while Ying listens to them
and burns in anger. After they leave, she decides
to take revenge on all of them and be the next
shining star. She executes her plan that very day.
First, she attacks the girl in the sixth position
with a wild cat that scratches her face. Then,
she puts ants on the towel that two of the girls
use on their faces. By the third time, she grows
impatient. She knocks a girl unconscious and trims
her hair and eyebrows. For the girls in the second
and third positions, she mixes a chemical in their
drinks which gives them a hairy face. Now, the
only person she has to defeat is Gade. She mixes
permanent dye with a face cream which makes Gade’s
turn green. Since, the ranks are changing so much,
the top beauty app glitches.
The next day, Ying comes to school
and sees no one around. The trash from
the previous days hasn't been cleaned
and the top ten tower is also in a bad condition.
She walks in and sees Nanno inside. It turns out
that since most of the top ten girls have dropped
to the end of the list, even with a bruised face,
Nanno is in the third position. As they talk, Gade
walks down the stairs with makeup to cover up her
green face. Ying is left speechless. She doesn’t
want to go back to being just a tenth place
after having done so much to be the shining star.
Gade makes fun of her claiming that someone like
her doesn’t have what it takes to be a star. Ying
grows furious and attacks Gade. The two get into
a fight in which both their faces are ruined.
Gade’s makeup is removed while Ying gets bruises
and bite marks on her. After knocking Gade out,
Ying runs to the auditorium where the new shining
star is being announced. After some time, the
much-awaited shining star winner is announced
to be a girl that no one has ever seen. Ying
retaliates and asks for a reevaluation because
the winner doesn’t even go to their school.
Only then, it is revealed that the winner is
Chompoo who has had a huge glow up. She thanks
the audience in her regular stammering voice as
the former top ten girls look at her in jealousy.
Nanno smiles while looking at Chompoo, suggesting
that this has been her plan the entire time.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.